The benefits that Taylor eluded to included, include the fact that what we have
done by documenting an architectural style is encode our experience on it.
For example with the client server there are certain ways of, of dividing things
up and, and connecting them together. That, work better than other ways.
We also know, with client server what kinds of problems can arise and,
how we can best cope with those. And having that knowledge then allows us to,
reduce our overall development effort because we're not stumbling down
blind alleys. Architectural styles can also be encoded into Standards.
Standard sometimes call reference architectures. And those Standards can then
support the validation process, the way that we check whether our architectural
solution is, is a good one. Architectural styles can also support Reuse.
The fact that there are, all kinds of, client server.
Systems out there means we maybe able to make use of standard
components such as [UNKNOWN] database server. And because different styles
provide different ways of, of structuring the development process, we may even,
even be able to. Use the, the style to guide us in,
in what our groups should look like and the steps that they should take
when validation can come and so on. What I'd like to do now is have a look at
some of the different architectural styles that have arisen over the years